so my name is andrew farah i'm
co-founder and ceo of a company called
density
over the past seven years we have raised
a little bit north of 100 million
dollars in a
variety of rounds with some really
awesome
investors in trying to fundraise um
the number of mistakes that i've made in
running or not running a process is like
way too many to count
and so um instead of sort of like
showing a deck
about like how to fundraise i thought uh
it would be helpful to just
show a deck that we use when fundraising
that's been
sort of lightly redacted and talk about
like how we think about structuring that
why we think about this process
why the process is important and
how you can sort of practically apply
this to
when you're raising capital and i want
to caveat this to any investor who's
listening
the intention here is not to i'm
convinced that there are a number of
great businesses that could have been
built if they knew how to fundraise
better
we only fundraise every 18 months and
investors are investing
continuously and so getting good
at running a process and creating demand
or sort of competitive interest
is very much part of the job as a
founder and ceo
and everything that i'm about to say
about what to do in a process or how to
think about a process or how to think
about the psychology of an investor
is not to manipulate
investors it's just simply to to make
sure that
you know your last pitch is your best
pitch and so if you've only done your
pitch seven times
your pitch is only going to be as good
as sort of the effort that's been put
into that seven times if you've
done your pitch 50 times uh it will be
that good and if you've done it 100
in preparation before you sit and talk
to an investor it is much more likely
that your story will be super tight